in Ocean's eleven Brad Pitt tells Matt
Damon how to pull off a con it's
basically they don't walk too slow don't
want to fast be funny but don't be
memorable there's a really a sense of
like being aware of how I'm being in the
world because if I feel like if I state
cop and I start to walk you fast they're
gonna think I did something wrong but if
I'm walking too slow maybe they think
I'm you know facing them off somehow so
there's a sense of like just keeping the
cop in my peripheral vision and also
making sure that I stay on the same path
that I was started on even if I realize
that path would be the wrong path
because I feel like I just got to make
sure this guy thinks that I belong in
the area that I am and I know where I'm
going and on some level that's the same
way you behave do you see someone in the
street so you think is a violent
criminal subscribe on YouTube follow us
on Twitter and like us on Facebook